the election is over World Series is
over and Mike Florio from
ProFootballTalk is here to tell you if
the ratings will be climbing up as a
result Mike well if the election was a
reason they should spike this weekend
right yeah I doubt Browns Ravens here we
go well says ratings like Noah 19 I
don't know if that's your litmus test to
say you know what the NFL is back let's
go watch the browns and the Ravens here
should we have a better reward you've
gotten through the election is over and
thanks America for giving us Browns
Ravens eye when do you when do you think
you're gonna see something or the NFL
nervous is the NFL about this right now
I don't know that they're nervous damn
because to be nervous they'd have to
admit there's a problem I just wonder
whether and I hope there is a disconnect
between the public comments and the
attitude versus privately what they're
thinking and what they're doing you get
a lot of all it'll be fine all there's a
lot more that came from all we're still
the king of the sports world well okay
fine but that attitude isn't going to
make things better I think the
responsible thing to do is head to the
laboratory figure out the reasons why
the ratings are down and come up with
ways to address them whether it's
officiating whether it's the quality of
the games whether something they can do
with the schedules one of the ideas I've
been throwing out there and I know that
this will complicate life for NBC and
make it more expensive and fox and CBS
won't be happy about this but i think
that the week 17 approach to sunday
night football where we don't know which
game is going to be until six days
before and there isn't a game that
slotted for that spot i think they
should do that every week you want to
make sunday night football exciting make
it a big event we find out every monday
which game has been selected for sunday
night football again it wouldn't be easy
it would create hardships it would make
the package more expensive fox and CBS
would lose their mind but that's one of
the possibilities they need to be
thinking about ideas to make the sport
more exciting and more appealing to get
more people to tune in ed Werder from
the mothership just sent out a report
that tony romo not cleared to play I
guess medically he's cleared but he's
not cleared football wise to be able to
get in uniform against this
dealers is that what you're making of
this well look what I'm making it this
is they are going to ride that Prescott
as long as they can and if he wins at
Pittsburgh on Sunday that would be one
heck of an accomplishment because a
Steelers team that is desperate and at
home is not an easy team to beat if he
pulls this one off then it's his job
barring a complete and total collapse or
a serious injury and I think the cowboys
are slow playing this I actually like
what Jerry Jones said yesterday about
the issue being something that's not
going to be totally resolved at any
point this year why have a plan why
announce to the world what you're going
to do keep the opponent's guessing as to
when and if they may see Tony Romo and
keep the flexibility to give Tony Romo a
series or two here they're just to keep
impression case you need him for the
postseason but there's no mandatory
requirement that they that they say who
the quarterbacks going to be very can't
help himself Mike that's been part of
the problem I wouldn't tell anybody
anything just were progressing will let
you know when Tony is medically cleared
and but Jerry couldn't help himself with
this well yeah but that when you have a
commitment to appear on a radio station
in Dallas twice a week you're going to
talk about something and and this is
part of his gig showman he's a carnival
barker and he's great for the sport is
great for his team is great for the
league and look I think a certain level
dan and and I know that they have a high
degree of loyalty Tony Romo and they'd
love to win super bowl with Tony Romo
but Jerry Jones desperately wants to be
the guy who built the champion he knows
that very few people give him credit for
the team of the 90s that won three Super
Bowls in four years that was Jimmie
Johnson's team it was such a great team
that even without Jimmy Johnson they're
very Switzer was able to win a Super
Bowl he doesn't want to be the guy who
wrote sidecar he wants to be the guy who
who steered the ship and back Prescott's
his guy he can take credit for that
Prescott Tony Romo's Bill Parcells guy
he's one of the last remaining Parcells
players who got parcels discovered and
kept and groomed Prescott is Jerry's guy
and when you couple that with Prescott
playing as well as he is that that's
that's something that makes the feather
in Jerry cap a little bit bigger yeah
but it feels like he's trying to still
keep the door open for Romo even though
doc Prescott's his guy
yep well look let's say they lose to
Pittsburgh this week by 20 points and
Prescott has three turnovers and then
they lose the following weekend a right
you want to keep the door open it here's
the one thing that i would be worried
about if I was a Cowboys fan Prescott
continues to play well for the rest of
the season they get the 1 C 2 the 2 seed
in the NFC and then in the division
around the Packers are in town and it's
late the third quarter the down seven or
ten points Prescott's thrown an
interception or two what do you do what
do you do that because you know what
whatever you do if it doesn't work
you're going to hear about it for the
next 20 years you either should have put
Romo back in if you don't and you lose
or you should have left Romo out if you
go with them and you lose that is not a
good problem to have i know they like to
say good problem to have the only good
problem to have is no problem and as
long as romo is looming that is a
potential issue that happens in the
playoffs and we sought from prescott
against the eagles a week and a half ago
he got it together he played well they
got the win but when the season is
riding on when it's win or go home are
you going to trust the rookie in that
spot are you going to be tempted to put
Romo back on the field I wouldn't want
that temptation if I was the Cowboys
he's Mike Florio you can listen to pro
football live NBC sports radio NBCSN six
to nine a.m. Eastern the show prior two
hours also check out profootballtalk.com
what is plan B with the Chargers since
the Chargers themselves don't know what
plan B is well yeah here's the thing
after the rams got the permission to
move to LA there was that period of time
a very intense period of time right
after that where the charges and the
Rams were negotiating the terms of a
deal that would allow the charges in the
rams to partner up and the charges have
until January 15 to exercise the option
to join the Rams in LA but there's a
belief in leaked circles that the
Chargers don't want to partner up with
the Rams they don't want to be second
fiddle in Inglewood I believe that a
stain Kroenke were telling the truth he
doesn't want to share that market even
he wants LA to himself I believe that I
don't know that that's the case but I
think he'd rather have the market to
himself so what's the charges
alternative are they going to get to a
game of musical chairs with the Raiders
for Las Vegas now they moved to San
Antonio st. Louis bigger Oakland if the
Raiders mover las vegas i think they're
staying in San Diego now the outcome of
last night's vote
if I'm being Spanish I look at that and
I say wow only thirty-one percent of the
people here are willing to give me free
money for my stadium maybe they don't
want me maybe I do explore my options a
little more carefully but they have at
least through 2020 and there's some talk
to they're going to try next year
another stadium resolution that the
mayor would be on board with they have a
popular mayor in San Diego they think
maybe they could get it done that that
way but if I'm the mayor and I'm popular
I don't know that I want to hitch my
wagon to a team that couldn't get more
than a third of the vote on a measure
that was being sold as hey San Diego it
won't cost you anything because its
attacks on the people who come stay in
your hotels and motels and even then
they couldn't get one out of three
people to support it I'll leave you with
this uh full-time officials in the NFL
would that make the officiating any
better I don't know that the incremental
improvement would be worth the expense
because you autumn Utley would have to
dangle some significant money to get at
hockley to give up his law practice to
get the other accomplished officials to
give up their primary jobs but I think
it could make it better and it at least
creates the impression they're trying to
make it better you can in the offseason
subject them to training regimens and
nutrition and make sure they're in great
shape and do simulations and have them
at practice during the week when they
otherwise would not be doing their
regular jobs you can have them go to a
team practice and officiate the team
practice on Thursday there's a lot of
things you can do if you have full and
unfettered access i think the NFL's real
issue here is from a business standpoint
how much can we pay these folks and how
much of a premium agree have to pay to
get our best officials to continue to do
it I'd then I'd rather see them embrace
the concept of the video official who is
a member of the crew who is seeing
everything that we see and communicating
directly with the referee on site saying
for example that was roughing the passer
or that was unnecessary roughness on
Richard Sherman throw the flag with the
benefit of the big bright flat screens
that we all see and we wonder what the
hell the officials on the field aren't
seeing you brought up Richard Sherman is
there going to be any more repercussions
with that I saw carpenters wife dan cox
Mike
yeah not that she'll be fined or
suspended but she was pretty angry with
Richard Sherman running into her husband
yeah I mean he may get a fine for
unnecessary roughness and and the NFL is
already admitted that it was mistaken
and look I love transparency I don't
know how I feel about Dean Blandino
tweeting in real time that it was a
mistake while the game is still going on
I have no problem after the game
Blandino going on NFL network or coming
on your show my show wherever and saying
well yeah we acknowledge that was a
mistake but this is something about it
when it happens during the game that
makes me say why don't we have some
place the water Anderson's the one who
hears it and fixes bachelor pipeline and
there's a lot of cynicism about that
pipeline that they use that pipeline
back to the league office when they
shouldn't well they didn't use it in
properly on Monday night because if they
did they would have been applied for
unnecessary roughness there would have
been the delay game penalty and that
mess wouldn't have happened great stuff
Mike thanks for joining us I'd say that
that's Mike Florio pro football time the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience